foreign
to understand how detrimental some of
the things he says to my son are about
his ADHD behaviors he's one of those be
tougher you know we just he couldn't
thank him this would end and you cannot
beat ADHD out of a human being
[Music]
what in the world is going on this is
John with the Dr John deloney show
about your mental and emotional health
and your marriage and kids and your job
whatever you got going on in your life
we're here
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 and
shows not just about opinions right I
try to do my homework and if I when it
comes to the actual research on some of
these questions that we get and if I
don't have the right answer I like to
reach out to a friend
um who's a professional who lives in
some of these spaces to get some wisdom
and so just know
man if you call on the show my promises
I'm gonna tell you the truth and I'm
also gonna say if I don't know and I'm
gonna do my best to find
data supported like wisdom and not just
cool Instagram scrolly things that are
like yeah bro yeah bro so if you want to
join the show give us a buzz again
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask that's a-s-k and Jenna Kelly's out
of town actually she's at home moving
back into her house she's finally moving
back home into her house
it's been a wild six months for her so
wild six months living in a hotel and
all that yeah so she had a tattoo to go
horribly awry so it's been a whole thing
and now she's moving back home
it's pretty cool pretty cool so we do
anything special for her being gone
like mom's out of town you know we got
one day left we can think of something
all right let's go out to Arkansas and
talk to Holly what's up Holly
yes how are you
sometimes when people are like John I
like to yell my first name too John it's
so good
what's up not much thank you so much for
taking my call of course thanks for
calling sorry for hanging up on you
earlier what's up it's okay well I was
just gonna get your advice on something
and see how it goes
[Laughter]
let's just see how it goes you know what
that's probably the wisest response of
any caller ever so what's up what's up
well I need some help getting my husband
to understand how detrimental some of
the things he says to my son are about
his ADHD behaviors when he's frustrated
with him
um you're getting onto my business now
Holly well it's my world too that's in
my soul is this kid his son also yes
okay so it's it's y'all's kid yes our
child I want you to know that just as
the call is starting your language is
very instructive
and I'll tell you why in a minute that's
really important but go ahead okay I
won't interrupt you anymore go ahead
okay well it's just when we try to talk
about it
um I'm sure that I'm oversensitive and
overcompensate because I also have ADHD
okay maybe not go ahead um but he's one
of those be tougher you know we just if
he didn't spank him this would end and
uh I just we've got to get on the same
page but I kind of feel like we're not
even in the same Library
and I'm kind of stuck on this one so
when you say
oh man
okay I've got to say this first because
it's just
burning a hole in my chest and then I'm
gonna Circle back okay
for your husband for everybody listening
you cannot beat ADHD out of a human
being
you can't hit them
you can't spank them or whatever word
you want to use
for beating your child but you cannot
beat ADHD out of a kit
period end of discussion
all right so I needed to say that out
loud all right let's Circle back
um when you say your husband's
struggling with his ADHD behaviors walk
me through what are some things that
frustr what I mean what are some things
that are hard to live with with an ADHD
kit
well he my husband's super not ADHD so
he's structured routine
um always prepared and
my son is forgetful distracted impulsive
um you know forgets to where his shoes
are
um
doesn't hear the first you know a couple
times you ask him to do something he may
not but it didn't go in
um
just those typical things he's not out
of control or you know getting in
trouble at school or anything like that
it's just
um at home it's very hard for my husband
to understand
the world of an ADHD person because he
is so
regimented and
opposite
um
so this isn't what you're asking but I'm
going to put this out there as as a as a
point of reference ADHD is a complicated
thing but ultimately the the best way
I've heard it distilled down by the
great Gabor mate is
ADHD is a body's long-term response to
chaos
it's a disconnection
okay and there is even some evidence
according to Dr mate that that's that
begins in utero in some cases okay so
also
an over obsession
with routine and this is the way this
should be and this is the way this has
to be
can also be a body's way of trying to
create control out of Chaos
so I want to frame what's going on in
your home it may be two sides of the
same coin
okay
and you know this better than anybody
because as you said you've lived with
this your whole life
the thing that your son needs more than
anything in the world
as a starting point
is to know beyond a shadow of a doubt
that his dad loves him
not how he performs not how he gets
everything right and in the perfect
order but that his dad loves him
and that my friend is the place from
which the other behaviors can be
constructed because I'm also not one of
these guys that lets ADHD kids just run
amok that's nonsense too they don't like
that life either I didn't like that life
I still don't like that life I still
need High accountability
but it has to start from a place of
there's like I'm there will be no bigger
fan in your life than your dad period
and Mom is going to have to hold Sun
accountable too right so
um
here's what I see sometimes not
sometimes often I see one of a couple of
things one
dad is
got too much going on in his own life
and so the thoughtful patient practice
that is parenting is frustrating because
he in his mind and body he doesn't have
time for it that's number one or
there are parents who see any sort of
forgetfulness as
disrespect as lazy
because they also see ADHD Kids Laser in
on Legos or laser in on a on a video
game or laser in on writing a novel
right and so they say if you can do it
there you can do it here right or the is
that your house yes okay all right well
in all the dinosaur names why can you
remember that
there you go man
and and that usually leads to the third
thing which is
moms and dads everybody we all do it
um
we use our kids Behavior as some sort of
scorecard for how we're doing as as
adults
and if my kid can't put his shoes away
that means I'm failing and I'll be
damned if I'm gonna fail
does that sound that sounds right
yes okay I see there's this head shake
and
and feet on the husband's face sometimes
when looking at him just like like kind
of like he's throwing his hands up like
I just I don't I don't know what to do
yeah and you you know this because this
was you as a kid yes that yes but you
know that there is no worse feeling
being an ADHD kid and feeling like you
just failed your adults to the point the
adults quit on you
yes
it's it's collapsing which then sends
the body off careening trying to solve
for the chaos and the whole system Loops
back up except it Loops a little bit
faster and a little bit faster and a
little bit faster
because that body's telling that kid hey
because of you you ran Dad off
and that that's when my son goes in for
the physical
you know that's his I guess way to no no
that's that's going back to yeah what I
said a few minutes ago the number one
thing a kid with ADHD has to know is the
adults in his life will go to hell for
him
they will fight for that kid no matter
what and they love that kid no matter
what and that does include a ton of
touch especially from Dad
and from there we can have conversations
about choices and conversations about
upstream and conversations about getting
enough sleep and getting off screens and
some of those things that
um I've seen anecdotally and I think the
literature is it's kind of mixed but I
don't trust some of that literature
these days
um
the exacerbates ADHD I know sleep for
sure and I know diet for sure
um but some of those things Upstream
right and you know
when you get a full night's sleep when
your son gets a full night's sleep the
morning's different we all know those
things yes but man it's tough to get a
kid to go to sleep when he feels like
he's trying to fend off or or make his
dad feel better
which isn't his job so here's the hard
part about this call this call is best
had between me and your husband not
between me and you I know and I've gone
to therapy to work on mine and they
suggest
Ed not a feelings guy I don't give a
crap about that he is a feelings guy he
just has a very sophisticated mechanism
for shutting that stuff system down oh
yeah and he knows I mean he's I've
talked about how he probably has PTSD
and he's like well doesn't everybody
have something and just is he a vet a
veteran
no he grew up in southwest Little Rock
when it was Major gang violence and um
that so
he's got a lot of hardened
stuff there so here's
ugh
can I I've read scattered and I've
I've helped him understand he just he
kind of looks at me like I'm an alien
and okay so here's here's here's where
we have to go from here okay
um
and I and you know what I'm about to say
but me saying it out loud is going to be
very hard to hear okay
and I know I just kind of talked out of
both sides of my mouth but both things
can be true at the same time
um this is a very generalized
Neanderthal way of looking at things all
right but in the grand scheme or in the
in the anthropological sense if you will
it's mom's job to Circle up and protect
young kids
and it's Dad's job to protect the system
okay the unit all right now we're in the
21st century and most of us work on
computers I realize life is different
there's not people chasing us with clubs
but
I just paint that picture for this
reason
there comes a moment
when if your husband or your wife
depending on who's listening to this is
hurting your child
the other parent has to step in
and stepping in looks different for
everybody and I'm very reluctant to give
somebody their or what
statement that's something that is very
personal
but at the end of the day your husband
is choosing you handed him the road map
which is the book by Dr mate you handed
him that road map I don't know of a
better book
and if I was sitting there with my son
and I've had these moments in these
Seasons when I don't feel like I don't
like he's talking Spanish and I'm
talking like
I don't know Swahili and we are on
different planets we're not even talking
the same when everyone we're so
disconnected and somebody handed me a
map back to my son you better believe
that'd be everything else in my life
would stop
it's so in a strange way your husband is
choosing misery and he's choosing to
have a broken relationship with his son
not to head to Healing
he's also choosing to have a broken
relationship with his wife because
you've asked him to go to counseling
with you you've asked him to be a part
of healing the family unit and building
something new and he's looked at you and
said no
and that puts you on an island to either
watch this continue with your son and
let this thing continue on in another
family system and yet another family
system or you step in and say this ends
with me and my son
what is that what does that look like in
real life
that looks like you when there's no
fighting and you've heard me say this a
thousand times on the show not in the
middle of a fight
because that me lines are drawn at that
point
this is you saying Hey I want to go out
and you telling your husband I
want you and our son to have a great
relationship and my son needs his dad
and right now my son is a drill sergeant
or my dad my son has somebody who's
really frustrated with him and he has
the the distinct impression that his dad
doesn't like him much less love him
would you be willing to try something
else
because what we're doing is not working
he's not finding his shoes he's not
suddenly making his bed
and more more volume
more hitting More film that's those
aren't working will you be willing to
try something else
and I I'm I'm trying to intentionally
make this about
uh an offer of
I want your life to be better too
because because here's the deal your
husband doesn't want to have a bad
relationship with his son he's at a tool
he's out of tools right he loves that
point yes he loves that boy very much he
just keeps reaching into his tool kit
and he only has a screwdriver that's it
correct and quite honestly I bet his dad
had no Tools in his toolkit right
probably not so he's trying right and
I'd love that
I love dad says all the time I see I see
him and me because his dad's like super
soft guy now but he'll say I see I see
him or me and him all the time
does he like that or is he trying to
avoid that
my husband
well I mean
my thing you know I used to be like that
and now he's you know he's different
he's retired he's looking back on
everything and
um
so I don't that surprises me because he
is so
such a soft guy I I know many many many
men
who look back
and say man I would have done that
differently and sometimes it's I would
have kicked my kid out of my basement
right I let my kid play way too many
video games and I would have had his
butt in a gym I would have had his butt
out of the house I would have signed him
up for Stuff
and also
there's a lot of dads that look back and
say my God what did I do
I tried to beat love into my child
I tried to beat mental illness out of
them I tried to yell and kick and scream
peace into their heart
and I tried to get a kid to make sure
that I wasn't mad that was never the
kid's job
man that's a common regret
a really common regret so I want to
honor the fact that your husband loves
your son I know that I also benefited
greatly from having a wife
that said no more
because I was really frustrated when my
kid was two and my kid was three and my
kid was four I didn't know what I was
doing
and I had a wife that said stop
and it wasn't bad or egregious or
anything like that but it was I need to
get some new skills
and I would put my relationship up with
my son over anybody's
it's pretty powerful here's here's
healing in 101 for ADHD something as
simple as how old's your kid 10 10 yeah
perfect
I can't tell you the Magic in my home
um again I don't
not talking about my son's Diagnostics
or anything like that and having
Diagnostics
um
that they start a weekly breakfast
together and they just go talk and they
hang out
that they
play and wrestle together
that
we're practicing so when your kid
forgets his shoes
cool
let's go find the shoes
and if you choose to not know where your
shoes are then you're choosing to not go
fishing man because we only have this
much time to go fishing
and there's one or two times we canceled
the fishing trip and it's a bummer for
everybody
but we can't go fishing without shoes
and kids learn Upstream about choices
and learn upstream and it's not this
panic and this yelling and this oh my
gosh dad's gonna be so mad my kids know
they really really can't make me mad
because I don't give them that power
all of this is creating a peaceful home
so that the kid whose body is over fired
up all the time can actually function
just turns the music down on everything
and you've experienced that right
yes
yeah
I'm sorry that you have to watch this
because I know it's hard to watch
it is it's especially when I know
because a lot of it is I know what to do
but I kind of like structure and follow
through with some of it because I get
you know distracted and it may really be
important for you to work
well if you've got a chaotic home
because my I guarantee you you and I
could have another two or three phone
calls because this isn't the only thing
going on in your house I know
exactly well this is we've worked on I
mean because like I said I've gone to
therapy and worked through a lot of
things and
of thank goodness Dave Ramsey found his
way into my husband's ear several years
ago on the deer stand and so we don't
have money fights anymore
um so this really is kind of the last
but you're right there are several other
layers that kind of come back to this
um well if he would have the courage I
would love to talk to him and with a
spirit of love and a spirit of hey man
there's a different way to do this
and this isn't me wanting to fight
anybody I don't have no interest in
fighting anybody but I do want
dads to learn new tools for how to love
their sons
and I want parents both moms and dads to
have new tools to create households so
that their kids can be successful
and we've just had a generation of kids
that we thought we'd just get louder and
um get more angry and more raged out and
that would work and look around guys
it's not working it's not and
for the Bro Downs listening to the show
no I'm not talking about not holding
kids accountable accountability is a
Cornerstone
no I'm not talking about getting rid of
consequences are you kidding me
consequences are critical
[Music]
I'm also talking about 10 year olds
10.
six
four twelve
moms and dads we can do better
thank you for the call Holly I'll be up
man I'll be here for you guys holler me
anytime I can help we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right let's go to Emily in Austin
Texas what's up Emily
hey wow like real life oh it's real life
it's about to get rich what's up
hey okay let's do this I guess what are
you nervous about
everything I don't know I didn't think I
was and then all of a sudden here it is
I've had this effect on people even when
I was dating like I didn't date in
middle school but when I had like a
girlfriend
I almost made everybody nervous I think
I just did that for you I don't love it
for me I think it's weird okay go ahead
go ahead okay
um so I'm gonna read my question because
I swirl off so you might have to like
we'll be back in a little bit all right
um but my question is how do I let go of
my extreme fear of dying alone so I
guess my biggest fear is like this
unknown that comes with age like what if
I get all the time where am I just gonna
sit in a nursing home Forever Alone
um I've been divorced twice and I'm
scared to leave my current relationships
that's very toxic Because deep down I'm
almost 40 and I don't have kids and I
can't have kids and I feel like this is
my last chance for a family
thank you
too much no no no no
um this is one of those rare calls that
probably more than anything I could say
if you and I were just
sitting down talking somewhere
um
I would just sit in silence for about 30
seconds and then I would ask your
permission if I could give you a hug
and I would hug you to the point that it
got a little bit awkward and then the
point where your shoulders could drop
and you could feel that I love you
and there's not something wrong with you
because there's not
yeah
what happened in your first marriage
it was really young
wanted to have a family I I did have
siblings but
um they were older and so I kind of grew
up as an only child and so I was 18 and
a situation presented itself to get
married to someone with two tiny little
kids and so I did and
I raised them for five years I was their
mom
and then he um cheated on me and left
and moved to a different state and so
that just kind of ended abruptly
[Music]
um sit right there
I don't want to blow by how huge that is
yeah
like you were 18 years old you were
still a baby and then
you had an insta family
and
this was your this was your life this
was your family for five years
did you give up College in your dreams
for other things for this one path
oh yeah absolutely I was a crazy
the person who had
had through it all to it
to these babies because they were mine
and
you didn't just get left romantically
which is brutal you didn't just get
cheated on which is brutal
this cat stole your family
yep he's all my babies
right
absolutely I was very empty for a long
time yeah
yeah all right so then what happened to
the next one
so then I waited a long time and when I
was 30 I
um
got married again
we eloped and
um
because why not
and he was a soldier has had a lot of
PTSD
got into some really heavy alcohol
addiction
um to where he was going to rehab went
through rehab a couple times did a um
inpatient where I had to take them like
to the hospital to detox a few times and
then
uh sent to like a three-month rehab and
during that say he just decided he
wanted a life of Solitude
so three years into our marriage we just
didn't have a marriage anymore
I don't have to tell you how damaging
and hard it is to be married to someone
who's an alcoholic
yeah that was crazy because they're
staring you in the face but they're not
there
absolutely and you're making love to
them but they're not there and you're
trying to talk about the future and
they're not there and it makes you feel
it makes you feel insane
yeah
and then they leave you
right right
the person is there to do anything and
everything and I'm one of those write or
die people like I would I would have
stayed with my first husband after
cheating I would have stayed with him
through you know I know I know but you
won't ride or die with Emily why
I don't know why don't you like her I
don't know how to I don't know that's
fair that's fair I'll give you that
and then what about this person you're
with now
it's kind of uh
starting to remind me a little bit of my
last relationship with like a lot of the
PTSD stuff starting to to trickle in
um
he's a police officer with you know been
a soldier and War stuff coming up but
also just it's smothering like it's too
much constant like phone calls and
texting and this and that and it's like
it's overwhelming it's just too much and
so we don't know how to communicate well
with each other have you sat down and
said hey this is a lot
absolutely and he just says I don't
really care what you think this is how
I'm Gonna Roll
yeah it's kind of been like hey I need a
boundary of I drive to work for 10
minutes like I just need to not talk to
you for those 10 minutes or I can text
you that I'm on my way home but I need
to be able to just drive home for those
10 minutes and just decompress and and
then it's a thing it's always a thing
like can you please not call me 15 times
when I'm at work because I think there's
an emergency when well I just needed to
know if you need to take from the
grocery store you know it's it's a lot
it's a lot
and I'm used to being alone and and by
myself and this is you know the first
relationship I've been in for four or
five years and I it's too much like I
just
you you know your body better than
anybody
yeah over 40 years you've been
conditioned strongly to not trust that
body
yeah and you're either wide open
or you are shut them down
yep
and my dream for you would be to be wide
open
for Emily
so the
it's like
I was a licensed therapist and we were
sitting down talking
um which I'm not
I would go you know what let's do it
anyway we can do it we got a few minutes
go to the end go all the way to the end
give me a scale on one to a hundred how
healthy you are 100 being like you've
got to be kidding me super healthy and
then one being like
I'm Mainline
give me 20.
all right so 20. so let's say you're 75
and you're at the end of your life okay
absolutely maybe 70. maybe 70. yeah I've
got some money yeah I uh I used I
snorted brown sugar off the counter so I
I've got a lot of miles on my body so
um back when I was a kid so
um
I have so many questions about that but
we can trust me I had a problem I used
to eat it without a spoon uh anyway
um
so you're 75.
and you're in a nursing home and you're
all alone
describe that for me
I just think that you're just lost like
describe before you're thinking about it
I want you to describe it put yourself
there
just sitting alone in a chair just
sitting there where does that picture
someone else around you
I think with my
um grandpa when he had Alzheimer's we
had him even in our home but he would
just sit there just alone and
nobody really like
I see other families and you know uh
grandparents or whatever and you're
always taking care of each other's not
love there but
there's like I don't have any of that
and so I just picked her at the end of
the day just being alone like in a chair
just all by yourself getting changed by
someone that you don't know you know
what I mean just sad it just it looks
sad yeah
yeah I don't think that's end of life I
think that's right now
I think you're a good anxious person
like me and the rest of us that can
project our brains will spin up
narratives and stories that aren't true
into the future that we can worry about
in the present because I just that
allows us to not to avoid what we're
experiencing right now
yeah but you have a guy that texts you
400 times a day and you are completely
and totally alone
yeah
and you've gone all in twice on two
different people and they've left you
one for a bottle and one for who knows
what
and that feeling of I'm just sitting
here in a chair is right now
Fair
yeah
so here's my question
you can continue what I what you just
described to me in a few minutes I'm
sure you and I could could hang out for
a couple hours and you can tell me the
full story but in just a few minutes it
looks like it has been a slow
collapsing of
Emily
over the period of
20 or so years
and probably for honest and got into
your childhood there's probably some of
that there too
oh yeah
I could be a weekly segment if you'd
like
it's time for time with Emily
um
so we could go through all that and I
think it'd be worthy to go through all
that but we're here
right and so
let me just let me cast a vision for you
as though you're my sister
okay you're my friend
you can't go back and change that stuff
that happened even though it shaped you
in a profound way
the question I want to ask you is are
you going to continue to think I'm only
worth this much until you just can't
take it or they can't take it and they
they leave or you leave
but I think you're too stubborn I think
you're too right or I'd ever leave I
think you'd marry somebody who's abusive
and controlling
because ride or die
and
you can do that or
you can live wide open not for some some
person who's going to come in and rescue
you
but for you
so my question would be
what will you have done when you're
sitting in this rocking chair and you're
75 years old
will you have gone skydiving or got
another graduate degree or play checkers
with old folks and all folks home every
Saturday or serve your local church or
try to would you will you have done that
will that be the story of your life
or will it be these hyper intense
relationships where you get set on fire
followed by half a decade of
isolation
yes that's where we are in one of the
you get to pick both Avenues
[Applause]
do you have a gang of like women there
in Austin that you hang with
where I came from because you'll judge
me but
but often recently from where
California I'm not judging you dude I
was just in Hollywood a few months ago
it's amazing it's the one of those
beautiful places on the I walked outside
like at 5 30 in the morning which is
noon for me back here not really but uh
to go get some coffee and I just
remember stopping and laughing I was
like oh this is why everyone on the
planet wants to live here was incredible
I don't judge you good for you I mean
it's good weather but yeah you're a
Texan so I'm sure you're aware I mean
we're not we're superior but I mean I'm
not gonna judge you right right okay so
here's a beautiful moment
and I usually don't like this kind of
language but I'm going to do it anyway
this is an either or moment for you
you're almost 40 right
yeah okay I made the same Journey
39 and a half I moved to Nashville
marriage barely barely hanging on
um
no friends maybe one or two like that I
had colleagues right some people that
I'd known that we weren't super close
yet or we had been close and not anymore
but but
I had a choice to make
I'm either gonna go all in and be weird
and just go make friends and invite
people over from work and take people to
lunch and put in my budget like this is
just I go to lunch a lot or I have lots
of coffee with people or I say yes to
every invitation to whatever
um you can do that
or you can just circle the wagons and go
home every night and watch wait for the
next Ted lasso season to start
and my challenge to you is looking back
over the last 20 years of your life
the Ted lasso route hasn't worked
would you be willing to try something
crazy and different for Emily now
I guess it's time
I don't know another path
or be that weird person at the gym that
asks people to hang out after meeting
them at the gym
I don't know like what are you into I
don't know what you do but man I mean
I'm only out of 20 so I guess
but you know what I mean yeah
and he here's it's it feels to me like
you have a very anxious life
can I run through a couple things with
you and you just say yay or nay or give
me like some quick data points
do you owe money
yes a lot
yep okay not a lot of friends
what's your calendar look like
empty your chaos
I fill it up with work okay so you don't
do heroin but you do work
correct yes what's your job
I am a director at a preschool
ah so you are
a crazy person yes no you're you're a
saint is what you are you're an absolute
saint but you also have to deal with
overzilla's parents 24 7 365. and you
have to deal with preschoolers and you
have to deal with teachers which all of
that is a lot
yes right but at least you didn't have
to do that during covet in California
and you did right so
I want you to understand your body is
doing the best it can to protect you
it's just doing its job
and you've created an anxious Universe
for your body to live in and it's really
hard every alarm you've got is going off
and they should be
and so if you reverse engineer this
thing
and say where or places I can begin to
get Freedom back in my life
so I give my body a fighting chance to
have peace my body has a fighting chance
to not be so anxious so I have a
fighting chance to go do things that I
actually want to do I'm tired of waiting
for people
yeah and that will be where you find so
and so
and you will be the best version of
yourself when you all do meat
I know that's the worst I know it's the
worst
go pack my bags
bags you know what I mean
yeah all right so what if I do this what
if I did this
so you know I work with Dave Ramsey here
what if I gave you a year of Financial
Peace University and the every dollar
app to help you pay off your what you
owe would you do it
that would be amazing okay done if I
gave you my book own your past about
dealing with your childhood stuff so
that you can be a functioning adult
would you read it
absolutely done if I gave you three or
four sets of questions for humans so
that when you're going out and being
weird you could be like hey I got these
cards and they'll be they'll they'll
either go you're an idiot let's do this
which is awesome or they'll be like okay
and it'll give you a pass if I give them
to you we actually use them
I will level my weirdness for you
absolutely excellent
excellent
and then it's just gonna be I give you
some tools but you just have to go out
and be weird and take a risk and go make
friends and get a community and start
looking in your life for ways you can
not be surrounded by a bunch of clutter
and not be surrounded by nobody
yeah
and let's be honest that fear you have
at the end of it all that's real that's
real
yeah but it's more a symbol it's a
representation of the death of this
fantasy you've had since you were a very
little girl which isn't gonna have a
family
and I'm going to be at the epicenter
Mike you've probably already have a
picture in your head of
the Thanksgiving where one of your kids
brings home somebody the first time
I mean I did but now I'm almost 40. I oh
so what now I'm just a crazy aunt that's
okay I don't I I know if you got
pregnant right now they would treat you
like you're a thousand years old or
whatever
but here's the deal yeah
um
I don't think you're done can I tell you
my mom's story have you heard me say
that on the show
uh bits and pieces
um I mean yes about her going back to
school 42.
yep and I'm trying to figure out a way
to surprise her in Oxford this summer
and I'm only saying that because this
show will be out by the time I'm gone
because she's doing her last year at
Oxford this summer at 73.
amazing I know but it's not weird she
just made some choices one little step
after another little step after another
little another little step
you get one shot at this tiny little
reckless Crazy Life we got
and you are worth so
so much
are you in
I'm in I promise do it yes
all right if you will take a picture
of the people at your first weird little
dinner party that you're gonna throw
okay
send it into the show and we will post
it in the show notes we will all
celebrate you everyone Across America
will celebrate you for going to be weird
and look here's why it's important
because you're going to provide people a
picture of what it looks like to go out
and take a risk
on dig a risk
because you know that being alone is
killing you
you know that putting up with abuse and
toxicity or whatever is going on your
life and I'm not talking to you I'm
talking to everybody listen
[Music]
skillet
let's try something different
you're worth so much more be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com
deloni today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to
Manhattan and talk to Omar what's up
Omar
Dr Jelani how are you partying man what
are you up to that's not true
I'm at work what's up man I've been
waiting I'm off from work today I uh I
took a couple days off I'm about to take
my daughter to a uh a water park for
um little you know celebration of her
finishing school this last Friday dude
dad of the Year man way to go that's
awesome well well well give it a couple
minutes let's see how you're feeling
about 12 minutes all right let's do it
go for it
all right man
um uh my my
um my wife deceased wife we couldn't
conceive so she oh you just you just
blew by that your wife passed away yeah
a long time ago seven years ago yeah we
were married for nine years she could
never conceive so we did uh uterine
surgery three cycles of IDs postpartum
depression modulation of progesterone
and estrogen all over the place she had
a friend who adopted a little girl from
China guess where this was going we
start the process and 18 months later we
we bring home beautiful little 26 month
old our daughter and then three weeks
later she gets a nosebleed doesn't stop
computerized tomography nine days later
it's already stage two within nine
months she votes to be with the Lord so
uh this was back in 2016. so um hold on
hold on I need a minute you may not need
a minute I need a minute
I know but you talk so fast through it I
know you've you're also running on
string and duct tape too
bro
yeah what was her name
uh her name was Bonnie and uh she
amazing and
she was gorgeous beautiful she loved
Christ I met her in church I mean she
was she funny
green eyes hilarious you know she was
wonderful did she put up with you to
remembering
yeah yeah so she she's a hood I believe
and I I think that I think the purpose
of the call is predicated on the image
and ideology I have sir of living in a
way to honor her life through my
parenting okay you miss me I'm with you
so uh um so so I am an accountant I had
just passed the CTA exam I was working
in the city and then stopped everything
to take care of her and then after she
passed never thinking I would have to
cap cash a life insurance check but I
didn't have to go to work so a mentor of
mine told me about a fantastic job as an
auditor for the state in the Department
of Education with 35 hours you know very
good close edging on six figures but but
the point is like 40 days off a year no
nights no weekends so so I guess the
point of my question is how do I not
resent myself and and the career career
trajectory I have in like this 18-year
slog 16-year slog of of like just
sacrificing everything to to make these
good choices for my daughter do you know
what I mean I could go on there's lots
of details I I super funded her 529 it's
you know God's willing it'll pay for
medical school or dental school or
business school or in whatever she wants
to go hey
um
hey yes sir
you've done real well
thank you no no no no I'm not blowing
smoke at you
your shoulders are up around your
Jawbone right now I can feel them drop
them real low
you've done a real good job
thank you sir that little girl won the
cosmic Lottery getting you as her dad
you haven't heard the jokes I mean yeah
funny but I appreciate that you know I I
I your whole I mean the whole the whole
thing right and I'm like you I laugh at
inappropriate times and if you're not
laughing at this point I don't know I
don't know how you stay sane right I
I I do you know what's your what's your
ethnicity Omar
um Jordanian my mom was from Germany and
my father was uh Jordanian okay so
you've got you've got a Germanic
Jordanian walking hand in hand with a
young Chinese girl down Manhattan yes
listen
you have done so good
so good thank you now yeah
now listen
two things that are super common when we
lose somebody we love especially over
the Long Haul number one many of us
don't have the tools for that I can't I
I know all the textbooks all the
whatever if my wife passed away tomorrow
I I can honestly tell you I don't know
where I would start
you get the grace you need I know I know
you do I know you do but you know where
I would end up I could almost already
tell you
yeah
I would work like a maniac and I would
try to make sure every variable in my
kids life was sealed up and buttoned up
because my body would be saying okay
you're the last one you're the last one
you're the last one what about you what
about you and I would I would dedicate
my life to button and buttoning up every
variable you've done that
the second thing that's really hard is
you're constantly looking at at this
beautiful little girl
but that was y'all's dream
yes yeah and so every day is a constant
reminder of y'all's dream and it's
really hard to
live in the present when every day is it
kind of got these glimpses of the past
with us right
yeah I tried I tried to fight moving
like because we we bought this starter
condo and I paid it off after she passed
so I'm debt free baby step seven and and
you know I didn't want to transplant or
buy a big house with a three thousand
dollar a month mortgage payment sir
because then I knew I'd have to work
more and that precludes my time with her
life skills discipleship all that okay
hold on if you if you work 90 hours a
week and you made a million dollars
okay let's let's do this thought
experiment you work 90 hours a week you
become one of the top over the last 15
years or seven years you become one of
the top accountants in Manhattan
everybody goes to Omar
but trust that guy he's a good guy he um
knows where every last
loophole is anybody's a high person of
Integrity everybody goes to Omar and you
make about a million dollars a year
mm-hmm
that money would be for what
what is the cross of demand to gain the
world and lose his soul what would that
what would that money give you it would
give you the opportunity hold on but it
does give you an opportunity to take
care of your daughter
to create safety for your daughter or
the illusion of to at least have her
health care funded in her med school
funded if that's what she wants to do
it would provide you some cushion for
when the world hits you in the mouth
which it will
right so I asked it has yeah it has well
I mean I mean it took an arm and a leg
actually I mean you got it more than
just a nose punch but
when it comes for you so I'm not one of
these guys that's like man why do you
work hard and make money no it's it's a
great buffer on the world but you've
been able to accomplish it also
my here's my question for you
seven years in how old's this little
girl nine months I mean nine years nine
years old oh she's she's ten she just
finished fourth grade 10 years old 10
years old you funded her college
education through med school about
you've got no oh no money
you've got a great stable job if you
want to call this the state of New
York's government stable
okay
are you being haunted by the question
is this enough
well I was writing my thoughts down
before and waiting for you know you were
talking with the other lady Emily I
believe yeah that's exactly it like when
do I realize a point of satiety in that
college private school 529 you know um
time with her yeah you have to you have
to do the hardest part that you've
you've probably done it but it's going
to be a real hard
I'm looking forward to her meeting you
we're coming we're coming God willing to
Smart conference in Chicago excellent
man hey we'll get you backstage stay on
the line and we'll get you backstage you
can meet everybody but I would love to
have you there okay yeah yeah and I'm
gonna bring her I wanted I want to
intentionally bring her excellent so
that she she gets exposed to all the
great personalities you know you know as
great as they could be other than you
yeah I was waiting for you to say it but
good for you all right here's what she
needs more than anything else right now
yeah
hmm
she needs her dad
yeah yeah
and
there's not a good
um
I can count money in a bank account
I can count baby steps if I'm a part of
the the Ramsey payoff your debt plan
I can count dollars in a life insurance
uh payout
it's hard to count
this morning when I asked my daughter to
stop doing something and she kept doing
it and asked her to stop but she kept
doing it and she dumped water all over
the back of my leg and she dropped water
all over the floor
and then 30 seconds later I went over
and I was making my breakfast and I said
hey will you come over here and crack
these eggs for me
and letting her help was a little
glimpse of redemption for her
and it would have been way faster for me
to crack my own eggs this morning
but I asked her to come help me
and I asked her to clean up the water
that she'd spilled
and I looked I bent down and I looked
right in the eyes and I said thank you
for helping me with my breakfast I'm
really grateful
and then she rolled her eyes almost out
the back of her head like a
seven-year-old and she walked off there
is no metric for that
but you know what that little girl knows
at the cellular level her dad loves her
and so behind bias I'm sorry no go ahead
are you biased about what do you do you
think I'm biased
by as I grew up without a father
so I'm trying to not only catch up and
honor my deceased twice but also
subconsciously be the dad I never had
honestly I'm sure that's a bunch of it
but I also think imagine you got a job
at an accounting firm and no one would
show you what a prepared tax return
looks like
DMS I'd get fired well they just yell at
you like go go go prepare taxes and
you're like all right what does it look
like and they're like go prepare taxes
and then you go on Instagram there's
like all these beefcakes and then
there's idiots and there's more on like
you're you are carving a path through
the jungle with the machete and there is
no path for you because you didn't have
a dad
and so every step along the way you're
having to look to the right or left to
see if this is the right way we're
supposed to be going and my fear for you
is you're going to have done all the
right things
and you're going to have missed an
opportunity to really get to know this
beautiful precious little girl
yeah I don't I don't want to do that I
know I know the purpose of the call
that's I want to tell you you've done it
man
you've done it thanks
it's amazing what you're giving your
daughter is a real-time picture of what
it looks like when all the plans in the
world get set on fire overnight
and you're giving your child a real-time
picture of what grinding it out over the
Long Haul making about one-third of your
quote-unquote market value
in service of
this precious little girl
and that's really hard when she's like
oh my gosh dad you don't let me do
anything right that's super annoying all
right
and
I can imagine that it would be easier
to be thinking about an accelerated tax
season
then talking about periods in the next
couple of years
or talking about like all that's that's
on you man that's all going to be coming
yeah and the more you put in the
relationship equity on this side of of
the hard conversations of the dating of
the being a teenager and the taking the
Subway by yourself all those things
which are tiny little rituals that are
just y'alls
you've probably heard me on the show say
every Tuesday of my life I go to
breakfast
at waffles in my son I don't miss those
days I just don't
and if I at the rare moment I have to
because I'm out of town at a speaking
event or something I'll we make it up
that same week
but just in the last few weeks we've had
some conversations that would not have
been possible had we not tilled the soil
for the last two years
and so I want you to look around and say
exhale really deeply
Omar
well done
yeah I I think sometimes I wait for
Christ to say that so when
when people when people say it
I on my own in my own thoughts I think
you don't know you know what I've been
through I know but listen and I'm not
applying that for you no no no I know I
know people confuse me with Christ all
the time nobody nobody nobody ever but
listen listen and this is important it's
important
um
I remember a speaker
and I have this image it's burned in my
mind it's one of the few times that I I
walked away is a before and after moment
for me
and I believe it was in Haiti
but maybe rwandos one of the two
and
um anyway there was just Devastation and
Devastation and some missionaries showed
up and they were trying to be do-gooders
and you know like a weekend kind of
thing and
they were going on a tour where there
was just a Mass Slaughter of people
and there was a monument to the
slaughter and there was a pastor there
and the people asked one of the people
asked the pastor
how do you still believe in God and see
all this
and the pastor's response changed the
way I lived my life
he said oh man I stopped asking a long
time ago where is God and I started
asking where are God's people
exactly and often when you ask for a
sign it shows up in a neighbor
when you ask for Words yeah or word you
ask for will you speak to me some idiot
on a podcast make all right
it's it's it's in it's in the homeless
person when you walk out off your stoop
it's in the person the bus driver as
they smile to you it's in the Uber
driver they're downtown
it's in your exhausted exhausted boss
it's in that little girl
and so you can white hole you can White
Knuckle you can hold the fist so tight
so this never happens again because
you've been through the worst of the
worst of the worst
you held the love of your life's hand as
she left
foreign
or you can open your hands and say Come
What May here we go
yeah I've taken care of my daughter
we're good she's good
and now we're going to spend days at the
water park like today we're going to
spend days at the park we're gonna spend
days laughing and going to see plays and
we're going to spend days serving the
poor we're going to spend days building
core memories so that little girl never
for a second doubts if her Daddy loves
her
we're uh we're going God willing uh
three weeks to Athens to on a short-term
missions trip I'm so excited yeah yeah
yeah for a discipleship you know for to
show her hey not everybody goes to a
private school and also and also and
also yeah
hey your Daddy loves you
well yeah um yeah yeah I got her
passport yeah I mean I know that you
keep talking about achievements
listen can you play me yes I can I can
gosh teaching relationships to
accountants is the worst listen so yeah
you can't 10 key this one but I'm gonna
give you a 10 key thing for it okay yeah
there is no equal sum algorithm on this
one all right here we go solving for
peace man I'm solving for peace okay
every day of your life
twice a day
morning and evening
say can I give you a special dad hug and
she's going to say what's that dead and
it's when you put your hands on the side
of her face
and hold it and she's probably brilliant
like her old man and you can tell her
some weird podcast guy told me that this
helps
and look her dead in her eyes and say I
am so grateful that God picked me to be
your daddy
you're wise because that's the Gladys
tissue on the cheeks exactly right
that's exactly right there's a lot of
Neuroscience behind it but I I I I leave
that to the hubermans and the tears of
the world but listen very good yes
that's right put your hands on her face
twice a day and look her in the eye and
let her know every single day you are so
grateful that you get to be her dad
and she gets to be your daughter
you've done all the stuff all the
metrics you've done all those things you
got her passport good for you
I want you to cherish and love the
relationship know her and I know your
body's gonna really fight you on it man
because you did that once
and the world took her
hard and it's real real scary
but you're in it you're in it
go all in
she won the lottery getting you as her
dad Omar
be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
Jenna's driving
she loves her some Macklemore and Ryan
Lewis she doesn't get tattoos though
actually you're the only one with real
tattoos that's funny songs called
growing up good grief Macklemore and
Ryan Lewis Ed Sheeran let's invite
everybody
foreign
they say Boys Don't Cry but your dad
shed a lot of all right this is good
that's enough for me that's
a song Do you like it
Nate Dog picked it
they say Boys Don't Cry but your dad
shed a lot of Tears they say I should be
a strong man but baby I'm filled with
fear sometimes I don't know who I am
sometimes I question why I'm here
I just want to be a good dad
will I be I have no idea that actually
is a good song that's not me nay dog
that's a good tune right there
good job Macklemore and Ryan and Ed
[Music]
I think it's a question we all ask
I just want to be a good dad
how do I do that
we'll see you soon
[Music]